as every year the european parliament is
interested in european cinema
it is the lux prize that the euro deputies
attributed to their favorites among
three selected films which speaks of
common european values ​​this
is the case of the enemy of the class of
slovenian director te reparle tv
met with a special mention from the public
being more awarded after the broadcast
of these films in the 28 countries of the union
north of france the city of arras
hosts a
film festival with a strong european tendency every year
and if we got them used to discovering that in the
end these films could
interest them that telling stories
wasn't complicated it wasn't
the image they had of it and so we
gave them confidence and today
they  are crazy about the pia and 35,000
spectators in arras but there are a third
of the spectators who are going to see the
unreleased european films grand premiere this
year the festival receives the three
finalist films for the lux prize the pri  x from
the european parliament for the cinema on the
id file
it is the story of a young polish woman
who, before returning to order,
sets out in the footsteps of her
jewish origins gangs of girls recount the
difficult life of a teenager in a
city ​​of the Parisian suburbs child
is the enemy of the class speaks about a
teenager in slovenia who commits suicide
and provokes a rebellion of her
classmates against a teacher at the
end of the broadcast of the three films
what did the  audience it's really
if it was in terms of cinephilia that
we had to reason we would say yes it's
really an admirable film we could
almost speak of my masterpiece but the
third
in this sense we let ourselves be taken we
let it go I had a preference
for the first until now and in the
end I think it's a
hell of a lesson in humanity should see
there my favorite it will remain ida for
the photographic quality but this one
does  think a lot  and it starts with
a film excellent level of reflection
on education europarl tv went to
slovenia to meet the director
of this latest film at the
filming location
the two young actors
who accompany him are amateurs who have
played roles  principals of his film
voran zulu case in the film
the leader of the rebellion who accuses the
german teacher of being
responsible for the suicide of his
classmate sabine interpreted
by purchase to be feared in the face of president
françois piquot
but that  think the real students
of this school believe that this
story seduced the star actor of the moment
slovenia we met her on the
boards for him too the enemy of the
class it's a typical
european film they come we all do
our vital gesture of this horrible
it's time for m for something
other difference with
american cinema european films
face language barrier
lux price offer three  s finalists
subtitling in all the
official languages ​​of the union, thus
allowing these films to travel more easily